que va devenir la droite demain et moi
je plaide inlassablement pour que l'on
tire toutes les leçons de ce qui s'est
passé et donc qu'on évite de repartir
dès le 2 octobre prochain sur des
élections fratricide pour savoir qui
sera le président de l'ump dans de
l'écurie thiaroye mon action je vais
pour qui une action collective pour
qu'il y ait un directoire qui respecte
toutes les sensibilités directeur s est
terminée le 18 brumaire sigean 6e vient
de laver à moi j'ai une vision peut-être
plus macro nist des choses je pense aux
directoires des entreprises voilà c'est
à dire d'une équipe qui tourne sur la
base du mandat qui dure serait donné par
le bureau politique et qui ensemble
permettrait de respecter les
sensibilités et de faire ce qui est
l'essentiel
un inventaire des raisons pour
lesquelles on a perdu donc lancer des
grands états généraux dans toute la
france avec les électeurs de droite qui
ont participé aux primaires
deuxièmement se dire que ce qui compte
c'est de former des nouveaux candidats
et de les investir pour les élections
municipales
et puis se préparer tranquillement 2000
pour la primaire vous 2020 pour de la
primaire quand elle aura lieu si elle
doit avoir lieu en 2021
donc il ya aucune urgent merci pour la
primaire moi je pensais que c'était fini
que celle-ci vous avez guéri de la
primeur pour toujours d'âge plus jack je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord il
bougeait jeux prince jean je ne préjuge
pas je dis juste que si nous n'avions
pas eu de primaire il n'y aurait pas eu
de débat serait t nicolas sarkozy
puisqu'il avait pris le parti dans les
conditions un peu brutale que vous savez
et à partir de là bas il aurait
probablement été battu aussi un nouveau
né le sujet c'est qu'on laisse ces noms
mais après chacun a son point de vue
mais ce que je sais que l'intérêt d'une
primaire dans tous les grands partis
moderne c'est de désigner en son sein
quelqu'un qui a vocation à rassembler
tous les fils que normalement rebufer
française à lyon
est ce que vous voulez faire partie je
s'excuse michel est ce que vous voulez
faire partie de cette direction
collégiale
pourquoi pas bien sûr mais c'est encore
une fois si le super sub à ma personne
qui compte moi de toute façon je suis
plutôt dans une phase aujourd'hui
d'observation je vais pas être dans le
premier feu parce que c'est pas
aujourd'hui ce que je souhaite faire
et puis je veux prendre le temps de la
réflexion ce qui s'est passé est très
grave la droite a été en réalité dans
cette affaire humiliée ridiculiser du
fait de d'agissements de comportement de
choix politiques de choix personnel qui
ont été désastreux donc il faut prendre
le temps de la reconstruction et ce
temps de reconstruction il
ce sera sûrement pas par une
radicalisation avec je ne sais quelle
mouvance du type sens commun ou pire
encore comme je l'entends parfois de
clin d'oeil à tel ou tel responsable du
front national parce que si c'est ça on
est assuré de perdre pour toujours
donc il faut reconstruire une droite qui
soit moderne qu'il soit totalement
étanche et le fonds national et dans
laquelle puisse s'ouvrir des discussions
où chacun ait sa place ou en soit pas
dans des logiques d'exclusion parce
qu'effectivement moi je les dis je veux
être constructif par exemple sur les
questions de code du travail
je serai en revanche en opposition sur
par exemple la hausse de la csg voilà
donc il ya des sujets sur lesquels on
doit pouvoir être moderne vous